bachelor nation you have a new leading
man Peter Webber I'm Peter I'm 27 I live
in Westlake Village California and I'm
an airline pilot known as pilot Pete
Weber was a finalist on Hannah Brown
season of The Bachelorette last year
very spontaneous person he just hop on a
plane like hey we want to be there or we
want to go there and famously spent the
night in a windmill with her during
fantasy suites if there was something
that Peter and I did twice it was
actually 14 he dubs himself a romantic
and when brown broke up with him in
Greece Weber left in tears the native
from California says he promises a love
story like never before his parents have
been together for decades they're his
example though the choice isn't without
controversy many fans were calling for
Mike Johnson to be named the franchise's
first black bachelor ever bachelor
nation alumni weighed in I don't think
one is necessarily better than the other
but I think Peters an outstanding
candidate I think I think America is
gonna fall even more in love with Peter
he's just such a good guy super open
about where his head's at what he's
feeling and that's just not what you see
from a lot of people how do you think
his season will be different
Peter seasons gonna be I feel like he's
gonna have a really really emotional
season because I think from the get-go
he's gonna have probably like a solid
connection with some women right off the
bat and it's gonna be hard for him to
figure out and kind of navigate what
that whole experience is like seems like
he loves hard
he loves hard and I think you know it's
really quick too so he's he's gonna be
in for a wild one for sure
he's the man who win milled it with your
dear friend Hannah
IOP windmills and all season
now I hope that I think he'll be a great
bachelor and I hope he kind of finds his
own little fun thing about you know we
had the fence and we had the windmill I
can't wait to see what Peter's fun
little thing will be windmills - plane
coming on my own high club yes Peter get
it
yes theater The Bachelor films in the
fall and the new season premieres
January 6 2020 on ABC
[Music]